tony blair is with us former prime
minister of course mr blair thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning you say in response to the
government act now what does that look
like
i think what it it looks like case first
of all um to accelerate the booster
program i mean we're doing about 165 000
a day we think you need to take that up
to 500 000 and you could do that if you
put in place the right mechanisms we
need to accelerate the vaccination of
children
we're falling quite far behind now
france italy germany in the vaccination
of 12 to 17 year olds and we need to
make sure that pregnant women which are
who are making up a quite large
proportion of those people in icu at the
moment we need to step up the campaign
to reassure them that vaccination is
sensible and they're much more at risk
of covert than they are of any problems
resulting from vaccination so i think
there are we've suggested in our report
12 separate measures it's not that the
government don't have in place
the things that are necessary it's
really a call for an accelerated sense
of urgency because if you look at if you
for example look at the uk today and
compare it with france italy germany
whereas at one point during this
pandemic you could say we were well
ahead on vaccinations and doing far
better
now when you look at our case levels and
hospitalization levels they're several
times the rate that they are in those
countries so it may be as the health
minister says
the pressures are are sustainable for
the moment but i think
really from an abundance of caution
because we've always been surprised on
the downside with this disease it would
be sensible to take these measures now
with as i say that sense of accelerated
urgency
so lots to talk about and unpick there
let's just deal with
how many beds are available in the nhs
to start with the government is saying
we've got six thousand extra beds for
now frontline workers are saying that's
absolute nonsense you're falling on the
side of the government finale
no i'm i'm i'm really saying that that
um we may have some beds extra beds
available and you know there's dispute
about exactly how many and so on but the
point is we're coming under increased
pressure
and
we're running it north of 40 000 cases a
day i mean the figure in italy is 3000
cases
they actually was speaking to someone in
the italian government last week they
think that's too many so we are well in
advance of that
you've just got to say what's going to
happen as we approach what will always
be difficult because you always do for
winter pressures on the health service
if those cases reach levels north not of
40 000 but of 80 000 or 100 000 as the
health sector was saying yesterday so
it's it's if you're looking it's not
right at this moment that the situation
is unsustainable but it could develop
that way
okay so the government is saying in
response to that because i put it to the
minister this morning he's saying what
else can we do we've got the jabs we
need the arms and that's also what we
heard from the health secretary
yesterday and so basically shifting the
responsibility to the general public
they need to come forward for these
vaccinations to try and bring down these
covet cases
yeah but i think that this is where i
would disagree with them i think there's
a lot more that they can do to make it
clear to people why boosters are
necessary if you take for example
because my institute studies what
happens around different parts of the
world if you take what's what happened
in israel
and they went through they got
vaccinations probably quicker than any
other place in the world they got people
double jabbed
everything was going
pretty well but what happens is after
about six months
so the evidence seems to show the
efficacy of the vaccination starts to
wane and as a result of that waning then
people even if they're double vaccinated
can be liable to get
covered and of course they've got
underlying conditions or other problems
then they can be seriously ill or
hospitalized even potentially die from
it
so that was the situation they then
moved to booster shots and they've
really taken care of it as a result of
that
so what the government needs to do is is
increase that capacity to give boosters
and make it far more easy for people to
do it so you know at the moment it's a
bit of a struggle when you're trying to
put your booster shot it should be easy
you could allow pharmacies for example
to be doing it alongside the flu shot so
that's one very simple thing to do the
other thing is to have a much bigger
push with pregnant women to explain to
them i think that the the figures are
still
fewer than half of pregnant women are
actually being vaccinated not in their
in the the the figures not just the
percentages but the actual figures and
the data on
vaccination and the impact
on on that the health of the country and
the truth of the matter is the evidence
that vaccination works is literally okay
it's overwhelming i mean there's just
there's no doubt about it at all and by
the way pfizer and astrazeneca are both
excellent vaccines as is moderna and
other vaccines so you've got you've got
a situation where once you if you really
take this out to people and say to them
look just look at the data
it's clear you know vaccination works
the absence of vaccination your failure
to get vaccinated doesn't just put you
at risk i think this is what is
important in a way if this were just a
personal decision for people and you get
vaccinated you don't get vaccinated it's
you who suffers if you don't but it's
not you who suffers if you don't simply
it's also other people and there are
people who are unvaccinated they come
into contact with people
even those who are vaccinated now they
can still transmit the disease and if
those people have got a serious
underlying condition they can actually
die as a result of that so
i think you know i understand people's
objections but at some point you've got
to say to people look
the evidence not just from britain but
around the world is crystal clear
there's not there's there's no
serious person disputing it
and to get vaccinated is is actually
part of your it's almost part of your
civic duty
something that i know you will have a
view on is kovacs uh former prime
minister um as you'll know uh the uh
british government said that they would
provide 80 million vaccinations to
kovacs which for the benefit of our
viewers helps people in countries around
the world who wouldn't have access to
these vaccinations otherwise up until
now we've only supplied seven percent of
that and even worse we took half a
million of those jabs back to be used in
the united kingdom how can that be
morally correct
well i think we need to do far far more
on this of course i mean i've always
said to people you can't expect
governments not to look after their own
population first and so i think it's
it's natural that the uk for example
wants to give its booster shots in in
order to protect its population but the
truth is we're producing larger
quantities of vaccine and i i hope by
the way
in november and december and certainly
in the early part of next year you
should get a lot of vaccine flowing i
mean the biggest problem to be to be
fair okay that you've had on with kovacs
is that the vast bulk of the kovacs
purchase was to come from the serum
institute in india that is producing
probably 150 to 200 million doses of
astrazeneca vaccine a month
because the indian government got a huge
surge of cases themselves with the delta
variant then they
they have taken most of that vaccine in
order to vaccinate their own population
but that situation is easing now and we
should be able to get much more
astrozenica vaccine to the developing
world in the next few weeks yeah but
that doesn't really answer my question
for former prime minister which is we
gave them these doses far fewer than we
should have done anyway but the point is
we did donate these doses and then we
took half a million back when i think
something like 3.6
of the african population has been uh
vaccinated and that and these doses were
for countries like that and we took it
back
yeah i understand that but my point is
that we are actually giving substantial
numbers of doses of course we should do
more everyone should do more and
what i'm trying to say to you is i think
you'll find that over the next few weeks
because my institute works in many of
these african countries you know the the
vaccination will start to flow i
actually think the biggest problem in
these countries okay in the next few
months is going to be how they absorb
those vaccines and actually get them
distributed to their population so
you're not wrong of what you're saying i
mean i agree with you but i think that
situation should ease not just in
respect of the uk but in respect of the
us and europe over the next
few weeks and certainly over the the
next few months but then we're going to
have to turn our attention to how we
make sure those facts vaccines get into
people's arms because that's a big
challenge in many of these countries
okay just before i let you go when are
you going to return to frontline
politics to sort your party out don't
swerve it just tell me
no i don't think that's uh on the on the
agenda which
will probably be to the relief of
many of your viewers
agenda ever or any time soon
no no no no no okay honestly i'm i'm not
uh i'm i'm not thinking about that at
all i mean look i'm i'm very happy with
with uh with what i'm doing but it it's
kind of you to ask
you're very welcome former prime
minister thank you for joining us on the
program this morning thank you